2026年10月11日(Sun)の投資レポートです。
ウォッチリストと検討中の銘柄、合わせて23銘柄を追いかけています。
今週、値動きが大きかったのは、Moderna, Inc.がプラス14.2パーセント、BioNTech SEがプラス5.3パーセント、ファーストリテイリングがマイナス4.0パーセントでした。
それでは、検討中の銘柄から見ていきます。
共立メンテナンスです。
現在値はおよそ3280円、前日比プラス2.1パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、いま拾って良い水準。
業績と株価が逆行しており、ここは時間を味方にできる局面。
理由は、2026年3月期は売上2,752億円（プラス20.2パーセント）、営業利益248億円（プラス21.2パーセント）で3期連続の過去最高益。
にもかかわらず株価は2025年7月の3,785円から11月に2,663円まで下げ、その後2,800円台で推移している。
業績の伸びが株価に反映されていない状態が続いている。
リスクとしては、円高進行によるインバウンド需要の減退。
人手不足による出店ペースの鈍化。
ホテル用地・建築費の高騰で新規投資の採算が悪化する。
次に、ファナックです。
現在値はおよそ6100円、前日比プラス1.4パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、日本製造業の復活に賭けるなら本命の一角。
設備投資サイクルの底で拾いたい。
理由は、2026年7月16日、NVIDIAのCosmos連合に安川電機・川崎重工・クボタ・富士通らと並んで参加を表明。
工場の自動化データを持つ側として、フィジカルAIの中心に据えられた。
ジェンスン・ファンCEOは『日本が近代的な製造業を発明した。
いまその日本がAIファクトリーを建てている』と発言している。
リスクとしては、世界的な設備投資の減速。
中国の工作機械メーカーによる低価格帯からの侵食。
円高による輸出採算の悪化。
次に、ハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズです。
現在値はおよそ6220円、前日比プラス1.0パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、ヒューマノイドが話題になるたび跳ねる銘柄。
テーマが冷えている時に仕込むのが定石。
理由は、精密減速機（波動歯車装置）で世界シェア首位級。
TeslaのOptimusをはじめヒューマノイドの関節には必ず減速機が入るため、Teslaを買うより素直にロボット化の恩恵を受けられる位置にいる。
リスクとしては、ヒューマノイドの量産が想定より遅れた場合の失望売り。
中国メーカーによる減速機の内製化・低価格化。
以上で今回の投資レポートを終わります。
またお聞きください。